-Standing ovation
for Kelsey Grammer.
-Very nice.
My goodness.
-Oh, my God.
I'm so happy you're here.
Thanks for being here.
-Thanks, man.
-I was asking you backstage if
you ever had a perm or anything,
and you go, "No."
-No, no perms for me.
-Nope.
Never a perm.
But then you gave me a picture,
and I didn't know --
-There is some evidence
of hair work in my life, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! Look at --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good-looking.
That's a stud!
That's a stud right there.
Real long hair.
What were you into?
-This is when I was
17 years old.
I was a surfer back then.
But --
And I used to --
When I would drop in like this,
I would feel the hair would
splash down on my back.
-Really? That long?
-You drop it in so it's --
And then there'll be a lift,
and you drop in,
and then the water would just
flow down my back.
And I thought,
"This is the best life ever."
[ Laughter ]
-That's so cool.
Eventually you ended up
cutting your hair --
-Looking like this.
-Later that same year.
What made you cut it?
-When I was in tenth grade,
I ran for the student council.
And we all gave a damn
back then.
And we thought, "You know what?
Damn it.
We're not gonna live by this
hair code crap anymore,"
in my high school
that I went to.
And -- so, they agreed.
They said, "Yes, let's do that."
Then they hired a new principal
the next year.
So, my junior year, they said,
"Back to the hair code."
And we said,
"Damn it. We say no."
-Yeah, we want to be able
to grow -- hair freedom, yeah.
-So, I went shopping for a wig.
[ Laughter ]
And I saw, in a wig store,
in one of the malls
in Fort Lauderdale,
a Jane Fonda wig.
And I thought,
"Well, that should work."
It was kind of long, though,
so I thought,
"Well, I'll just
cut the back of it off."
So I just cut the back off,
and I shoved all that hair
underneath there.
-Wait.
So it actually is a wig?
-It is a wig.
And then --
-So you wore a wig to school?
-I would go like this.
Put my hair in a ponytail,
put it up on the top of my head,
and I'd go like this,
and I'd go like that,
and I'd pull it back down.
And I thought, "If they're
willing to let me look
this stupid,
I'm willing to do it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's the best.
Did everyone --
[ Laughs ]
Did everyone know it was a wig?
-Everybody knew it was a wig,
yeah.
-They knew it was a wig.
-There were three of us --
Ronnie Powell,
Bob Collier, and me.
-I love it.
-Bob and Ronnie both quit
about halfway through,
but I stuck it out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Good for you.
Jane Fonda wig.
I love that story.
Before we get into the movie,
can we talk about, right now,
you're shooting --
you're filming the reboot
of "Frasier."
-Yes.
-This is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And people
are talking about this.
It's exciting.
Is it strange to revisit
a character that you haven't
played in 20 years?
-Well, it's funny.
People used to ask me years ago,
you know, "How have you kept
this character alive
for as long
as you have already?"
And I said, "Well, it's like
waking up in the morning.
You know, life is interesting."
-Yeah.
And so a character that sort of
walks hand in hand with you
through your lifetime
is equally interesting.
As long as you don't, like,
drop the ball.
As long
as you don't stop caring."
And so I never stopped caring.
It was actually when Roseanne
got her show back on,
I thought to myself,
"Well, you know,
Frasier's kind of interesting."
[ Laughter ]
"We could maybe play him again."
-Yeah, and then the rumor is
that he's moving back to Boston.
-Right.
He's going back to Boston.
Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait, wait, for a --
You gotta come back for that,
okay?
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about
your new movie.
It's called "Jesus Revolution."
-Well, you got two choices.
"Cocaine Bear"...
[ Laughter ]
...or the living Christ.
Which one you want to go with?
-Oh, my goodness.
I never thought of that. Yeah.
-But surely, on February 24th...
-You've got options.
-...everybody's gonna be happy.
[ Laughter ]
-You can make some choices.
-There's something
for everybody.
-Theater A or theater B.
Yeah.
Wow. Yeah.
Or make a whole day out of it.
-Or the guy
that rose from the dead.
One or the other.
-What drew you to do this film?
-Well, the truth is,
I was having a sort of
a meditative evening
one night in my home.
And I was up pretty late.
It was about 3:00,
4:00 in the morning.
And I started thinking, "I want
to do something worthwhile,
something that has a bigger
purpose than just me."
And I was kind of
saying a prayer, I guess,
and the next morning,
the script lands on my door.
And I read it, and I said,
"Okay.
That's it.
I'm doing this Jesus story."
-Yeah.
-It was pretty cool.
-This script came to you.
I'm so excited.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kelsey Grammer
in "Jesus Revolution."
Take a look at this.
-You tell me right now
where my daughter is.
Jeanette!
-What?
Here.
-Who is this?
-It's Lonnie.
-Hi.
Uh, would you mind just, uh...
stepping outside
for a minute, mister...?
-Not at all.
Frisbee, Lonnie Frisbee.
-Frisbee.
Thank you.
-Sugar, by any cha--
-What is going on?
-You said you wanted God
to send you a hippy.
-I said that...
but I did not mean it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on.
That's how to do it right there.
Kelsey Grammer, everybody!
"Jesus Revolution"
hits theaters February 24th.
Please come back whenever,
buddy.
You're the best.
Kelsey Grammer.
We'll be right back.
Come on.